pure a tutti quanti sopravvissuti del
duca
c'è un francesi xvi sec del game del
bunker quello del lavoro antonio quello
e da un sacco di tempo ragazzi che non
vinco a sixty seconds saranno passati
dall'ultima volta che ho vinto è stata
l'unica volta che una volta ho vinto è
stata con pietro restiamo parata del
2017 somma 63 anni se non vinco da mai
quindi ragazzi questo titoli o avete
rocchi o vita si secca non sa che si
tratta hanno ancora giocato qui non so
se andrò vincere però detto che lo
scrivo di sopra perché da un po che non
scrivo che ho vinto come cosa molto
importante poi vediamo di vincere sul
serio se non ha senso titolo xi però lo
mettiamo ogni sette giorni mangiano ogni
tre giorni devono questo discorso che
non ho qua finiamo che mettiamo scemi
allora ragazzi ho salvato saltato i
primi giorni perché non erano tanto ti
siamo al 5 allora iniziò a fare cose dal
5 in poi non siamo soli sembra action
conigli e norme e peloso nascosto in uno
dei tubi a volte ti la follia testa non
possiamo promettere che sarà ok
ammazzalo amata lo ammazza al coniglio
magari abbiamo cibo in più che cacchio
so vediamo
non ho mai ammazzato coniglio sbaglio
vediamo cosa è successo
le nostre attive sono stata perché
voleva rubarci le lattine
vabbè ancora un giorno ragazzi per darli
da mangiare che se non ho un senso porta
segreta dietro la credenza del rifugio
vai qua dovrei trovare il credo una
lattina di cibo teoricamente se non
ricordo male vediamo fucile e comunque
ragazzi in tutto sto casino
ero riuscita a salvarmi l'unica volta
sempre che i militari perché ci sono
tanti altri modi per salvarsi è quello
di scorsi come mai così difficile suo
george direi a questo punto di non
mandare ancora lo facevo la maschera
cielo la maschera antigas poto mandare
subito qualcuno veit ed immediatamente
ce l'hai la martino lavora anche vista
la maschera non sono un pirla e quello
serve e usiamo la nostra mattina ci
stava osservando in un angolo rifugio
penso si tratti di un topo ammazzar dopo
collage accusiamo lascia per gli animali
ragazzi finché non si rompe ed è il
momento di indossare quella [ __ ]
maschera chiama da mangiare a tutti
perché nessuno ha mangiato ragazzi e
hanno bevuto l'ultima volta quattro
giorni fa guidò anche davvero ok allora
mangiare bere ed torna mi raccomando
quanta roba che torna con rob e decenti
non tornaco cazzate team bernando slash
surf timber man s ii
ho pagato il gioco dolores vorrebbe
tanto sa già qualcosa timi ha molta fame
le licenze ferita ma come se ferita dove
dovesse colonne si è ferita per dj ma
vaffan
no non glielo do al kit mori abbiamo
poche provviste il morale a terra la
disperazione ed rifugio si tocca con
mano
qui vicino c'è un piccolo gruppo di
sopravvissuti più che altro vecchietti
nell'ospizio non andare deve che ti lo
spinse perché ti in groppa non come
sempre quindi non andare dai vi chiedo
non andate da rubare i vecchietti per
favore non andate a rubare ogni volta
che qualcuno ruba i vecchietti perché ti
si incazzano come si è ferita questa
come hai fatto non c'è niente qua dai la
ventola acqua dei verbali e andiamo
avanti comunque tenta ancora non è
tornato
vabbè cosa succede fanny sta cosa hai
trovato la maschera l'abbiamo riportata
più 2 acqua più del cibo ma allora abete
pirlo che sei giocare dirlo se non fai
tu faccio partire dolores no dolore
serata mi sa che timi che deve partire
ragazzi lascio parcheggi amico la
maschera che tanti siano fuori
abbiamo giocato a finance tre le cose
con i di più è proprio che motivo 9 del
nostro vicino continuano a spuntare cioè
inutilmente calcoli ci dovete avere una
cassa porti salotto vai vai dal viscido
vicino ned flanders ne porta mi na roba
ai miei appelli pepsi canadian e del
vicino ned flanders sul serio io ho
detto per scherzare med veramente nè del
vicino tutti i vicini schiavon ed in
tutto questo ragazzi giovanni si è
ammalato ma non fa niente perchè tanto
lo mandò in perlustrazione quindi fa
niente bagni per l'usl action forti
tenere la tua malattia torni è sicuro se
torni vivo sicuro se non muori ragazzi
questa è la devo leggere nuovo mai letta
conoscevamo quasi tutti il vecchio jim
che arrancava spesso nella nostra strada
e ci salutava sempre una volta volevamo
fargli visita lui ci ha dato l'indirizzo
del parco il vecchio jim è un tal
burlone a quanto pare ancora vivo visto
che ora è alla nostra porta e si chiede
se vogliamo comprare una pietra ma che
appena eletto ma se così è che la compro
st pietra voglio vederla succede compro
una pietra voglio voglio la pietra meno
ai che non è pietro mi dispiace per
destò maruccio però ve lo do il 22 by
fammi vedere st pietra che senso ha
avuto tanto squilla un telefono che non
ho corso ho comprato la pietra pietre
noi amiamo le pietre e mary jane ne
avevano a collezioni minerali o bene
anche la più semplice rossa roccia
radioattiva un buon inizio ma no è
radioattiva con l'avevano scelta è molto
carina c non ha voluto nulla in cambio
certo che la porta fortuna che dovremmo
averne
oggi vento soffia il nostro favore ora
che ho comprato una pietra di merda che
tanto e radioattiva quindi siamo tutti i
malati tra un po mangiamo e vediamo
domani ragazzi pensavano che le
telefonate appartenessero al passato
visto che la bomba dittatura città una
cabina telefonica telefonica sulla
strada è riuscito a sopravvivere vai vai
rispondi tu dolores potrebbero essere i
carabinieri di borgo dora pronto lorenzo
che è tornato mio figlio temine no
serata maschera cacchio pronto cibo
importato tu poi sono il cibo che moana
il boy scout ottimo nella sua tana mi ha
attuato il cadavere di un operaio dello
zoo dato alcuni era dio artusi quel
lucchetto non è male di lucchetto non è
male meno una maschera cacchio non fa
niente fa niente male per il lucchetto
ragazzi
curiamo timi perchè giustamente sta
schiattando ne vai dolores e il momento
ha senso portarsi la fase che la mando
senza niente potrebbero in un senso ma
dalla stessa muscolare con l'ascia
tenendo con lasciava in giro con la cia
che se becchi qualcuno picchi
teoricamente lascia potrebbe servire
l'unica norma che viene da lì perché non
ti posso dare il fucile perché dimostra
di proiettili figli a quanto pare non ha
un senso chiede a posto si è ripreso il
comunicato l'esercito faranno una
perlustrazione della zona hanno chiesto
a tutti i sopravvissuti di lasciare dei
segni disegni dovranno essere le carte
vai
stavolta ho le carte che mi ricordo che
quando tanti anni fa avevo perso perché
di nuovo le carte ce le ho l usate le
carte sono posizionate ora possiamo solo
aspettare che l'esercito ci localizzi
non dovrebbero impiegarci moto in teoria
in pratica arriveranno al giorno 60 lo
ha da mangiare e bere a tutti ragazzi
così siamo a posto e siamo allineati poi
c'è un silenzio terrificante timi sta
bene ed è in pieno ottimismo
mando team mentre facciamo un conteggio
questo l'ho detto io sia stato timi
davvero curiosità incredibile il 31 non
era mai successo di editare
qualcuno è stato tim mi tieni al posto
di tom alacce timi è stato proibito
toccare i barattoli di zuppa fino alla
fine i suoi giorni anche quelli vuoti
perché poi daremo ha da mangiare con un
cucchiaio e toccherà qualcuno portava
spazzatura ha fatto solo ci ha dato un
bel rotto che puzzava in modo sospetto
di pomodori o meno una zuppa viking i
nettop con lasciati mi no secondo me chi
mi dovevo andare col manuale degli
scatti che è abbastanza utile credo noi
per sopravvivere figli con questo è
meraviglioso
vado a logica penso che ogni prezzo ogni
persona abbia il proprio strumento
vedo l'ora e scola scharner al massimo
abbiamo onorario funzionante usa l'ha
capito stiamo aspettando solo i figli
soccorsi quelli ancora non bussano i
maledetti dell'esercito sono tanti
talenti paraga col agenda vi sono messo
cribbio se non mi sono impegnato
stavolta non mi impegno non è più la
fame ben fame sete mangiate e bevete al
35 quando ti abbiamo aperto la porta
rifiuti abbia trovato una lettera terra
e non hai chiesto aiuto da parte di
gruppo di simpatici sopravvissuti ciò
porta gli stupratori di truffa siamo
molto molto simpatici e abbiamo voglia
di dare alla gente chiama la vera tutti
e due
nel frattempo proprio aranceto trasmesso
un altro messaggio l'esercito iachini
sono trovare un luogo elevato per
continuare a fare rumore
va bene con la fisarmonica meno male che
ce lo meno male che ce l'ho perché mica
a questo punto quante romeni di fare
cioè più difficile che chiamare
l'esercito che accendere la macchina in
meno di 13 è incredibile
cosa devo fare prossima volta giocare a
just dance speriamo che queste mutazioni
patriottismo porti sono andati da noi
l'inno nazionale hanno suonato vabbè
allora bere e gli ho dato da bere quindi
non mi conosci dato da bere
sì gli ho dato davvero da 34 gli ho dato
da bere non aveva mai immaginate vivere
a lungo vedere uno scarafaggio danzare
spray e ammazzavo deve morire fanno
schifo ma dimmi dove sei torna ti prego
ti amy tornerà se torna torna al 38 più
sappiamo di quel che accade fuori e
meglio è raccontiamo intorno alla radio
raccoglierci tornare stessi utilizziamo
ci vai sintonizzati
speriamo di no a romperla però dimmi che
tornare al 38 avevo detto io e quindi
non sei portato ad acqua
bravo e anche la zuppa lo zio bravissimo
come sei messo 6 ae la malattia non ce
l'hai è perfetto così possiamo anche
tenere il kit aver sentito no forse
perché nessuno parla e non posso oggi è
rotto il coso si è rotto la radio
semplicemente perché avete ascoltato i
sovietici che era poi erano i canadesi è
morta dolores dolore se avesse avuto un
po d'acqua ma che strano non è passato
così tanto la quando gliel'ho data
serata si è passato un sacco da mangiare
e da bere ted chissenefrega di mia
moglie
mangiare bere importante che tu abbia
abbia pensato che fossero toni ma la
terra qualcuno che bussa violentemente
alla porta
apri speriamo in dio che siano ai
clienti all'esercito non all'esercito
questo dolore se però proporta lavori
[Musica]